people think about corn fields when they
think about Nebraska and when they
specifically think about Omaha but if
you live in North Omaha things are
drastically different poverty
hopelessness we have one of the highest
african-american school-to-prison
juvenile detention rates in the nation
and we definitely need to do some things
to change that and one of those key
things being educational
you
for four years in a row but I've had a
bill to give you choice this year it's
back up again the number is lb 26
parents write it down lb 26 kids write
it down lb 26 look up every name on the
of the members of our revenue committee
and ask them to put it on the floor to
discuss it you know a zip code should
not be the determining factor of whether
or not a child gets a great education
now here in Nebraska we're very blessed
with wonderful public schools but we
know that every kid doesn't learn the
same and we want to make sure that we've
got that effective education system for
all of our tables what are the biggest
political obstacles that you receive
stepping dancing well as with any bill
you got to start with you know getting
the grassroots support for it and then
you've got to be able to craft a bill
that got to get to the floor the
legislature for for a vote so there's a
lot of work and ground work that has to
be done but it starts with events like
this when we lived in places where there
were school choice there were times when
we had kids in our family some at the
neighborhood district school and some at
a charter school because even within the
same family you're not always going to
be able to meet every child's needs with
the same school my daughter specifically
was a product of the traditional public
school setting primarily from pre-k to
fourth grade and she could not breathe
at all when she entered the fourth grade
she was illiterate and so I've had to
look outside the traditional public
school setting and when i did so i found
a private school that helped my daughter
that school costs a lot of money and i
had the means to do it but a lot of
parents don't and my daughter went to
that private school and in one year she
went from a non reader to a third grade
reader the kids behind us and all kids
in Nebraska deserve the highest quality
education possible and school choice
helps make that possible for every child
in Nebraska our children have been
failed miserably in our educational
system it's the
good life Nebraska our tagline is the
good life it's the good life for who